Saint-Louis...
- Il pleut littéralement dans
l'appartement de Wasim Osman,
depuis qu'un homme a percé
la toiture à plusieurs endroitss
sourds et répétitifs captent
son attention.Alors qu'il monte,
ce qu'il découvre le sidère.
Il décide de capter la scène
avec son téléphone
Il ne nous a pas été possibld'is
Il ne noté possible
d'identifier l'homme dans
la vidéo
après les gestes, une pluie
diluvienne s'abat sur Montréal..
Wasim Osman se désole que
le représentant de l'entreprise
Tristan Desautels, n'ait pas
fait les travaux de réparation
pour que l'eau cesse de
s'infiltrer. Il affirme
reprises interpellé
pendant trois semaines.
Ce n'est que le lendemain
de notre passage pour cette
entrevue
réparé. Wasim Osman et
trois autres locataires
dénoncen
l'Estrien Tristan Desautels.
Ils croient que ce laxisme
s'ajoute
déployées depuis son arrivée
pour les évincer. 7 juillet 7 jt
le lendemain de l'main de l'mai,
Tristan Desautels tenteincre les
ier leur bail.
Il leur annonce que le bâtiment.
- Mais c'est le chantagequ'il fe
et expulsés de notre propre
loyer par les pompiers.
- Dans un enregistrement audio
et un courriel obtenu partan Des
affirme qu'il ne suffit que
d'un appe les pompiers
évacuent les lieux.
de réconnexion, déconnexion etlr
dans le logement temporaire
devraient être assumés par le
de quelques milliers de dollars.
- Nous avons tentéeurs
reprises de joindre M. Desautels
mais sans succès.
un rendez-vous avec vous.
(bip! bip!)
Le groupe des quatre locataires
refuse de quitter leur
appartement tant eels
ne se pliera pas aux exigences
i.
Jean-Roch Boivin espère
quant à lui ne pas être
de l'embourgeoisement.
- Pour que ça s'arrête.
Et qu'il reste encore des
pauvres au carré Saint-Louis.
Excusez-été beaucoup jusqu'ici
parce que ça ne donne pas
de résultats.
- Les locataires ont fait
parvenir des mises en donneu
dans l'espoir de faires droits.
Ici Thomas Deshaies,
Radio-Canada, Mon